i'm sorry it was just oh you scared me  i didn't mean to  just wanted to see what you're seeing  be careful what you wish form  so when am i gonna get to meet this  caleb  probably never why  it wasn't a lie i didn't say it was  yeah well i know what you're thinking  what  you want to know if he's real  honestly i don't know if he is or not  i don't care i like spending time with  him even if he's an illusion  it's not healthy for you though how do  you know mom  you have no idea what it's like to have  no one to talk to i finally have someone  to keep me company and he's not hurting  me or anyone else so i don't understand  what the  problem is it's it's just  it could be a trigger  and you always have me to talk to that's  just not the same  why because i'm real  i'm sorry i shouldn't have said that  [Music]